I told my mom about it and she said well
what are you gonna do about it
so we decided well I decided but she
really did help me I'm starting a
campaign where black girls are the main
characters and I think this is important
because when you see someone that you
can relate to in a book you'll normally
remember the things that they learn so
then you can use them in your life to
make your life better
picked 1,000 because I think that it was
definitely 500 wouldn't feel like enough
because to be honest I probably do have
500 black girl books at my house and
that I've read so I wanted to be more
than I've read and just get new books
that I haven't seen before so that I
wouldn't just be me giving away books at
Ibrox so you chose the school because my
mother went to the school and so did
basically everyone in her family so we
think it's really important for her for
this experience here because it's
basically her Ruth and I want to do it
not just in America where I'm from and
step out of my comfort zone and go
places that I've never been in interact
with people that I've never met
it feels spectacular to know that I am
reading a book about black girls which
means I'm reading a book with people of
my culture that are in the book so it's
awesome spectacular
you